So this is the Mark IV Special Coffee Maker.
We're going to assume that it is part of a series of coffee makers.
It's the current one but it won't be long before the Mark V is coming out, so we
have to be concerned with you know, the, the whole family of coffee makers and
how things are going to change in the future. The Mark IV makes up to 12 cups of
coffee at a time. There's there's a filter that has to be filled with
coffee ground, and it has to be, the filter has to be slid into its receptacle.
The user then supplies some some water in, into the water strainer and
presses the Brew button. The water is heated until it's boiling. The pressure of
the evolving system forces the water to be sprayed over the coffee grounds and
coffee drips through the filter, your standard, standard coffee maker.
The pot is kept warm for extended periods by a warmer plate,
which only turns on if there's coffee in the pot. You don't want that
baking in those grounds and being unable to wash them out in the future.
If the pot is removed from the warmer plate while water is being sprayed over
the grounds, the flow of water is stopped, so
that brewed coffee does not spill on the warmer plate. Those are our
very high level description of what the Mark IV is supposed to be able to do.